euh on se rappelle tous de l'affaire
Lola et le père de Lola a donné une
interview il revient sur le meurtre de
sa fille et sur sa vie de famille depuis
le drame que s'est-il passé le jour du
drame son père raconte cette journée du
14 octobre 2022 où il a appris la mort
de sa fille CIT sur TF1
regardez mais je on l' prend vers
23h et quelque
chose par le le préfet qui était là qui
vient vous voir
ouais ouais qui était carrément dans la
résidence plus les agents de police qui
était là parce que un SDF a retrouvé
euh à retrouver le corps de notre fille
voilà où
ça remis devant chez nous devant la
résidence dans une malle
oui moi je pète les plombs
après c'est très mais témoignage très
très fort est très très dur après un an
il explique que sa famille a volé en
éclat et qu'il a vécu une véritable
descente aux enfers regardez il a
présumé coupable elle a pas enlevé que
la vie de ma fille elle a enlevé une
famille complète bah avec ma femme on
est on est en divorce aujourd'hui vous
êtes remis à boire ouais j'ai pas le nié
hein faut être honnête dans la vie
hein ça vous aide à supporter
l'insupportable non pas forc et l'Ola
vous y pensez en
permanence c'est pas en permanence
c'est une journée c'est 24
he bah moi je vais vous dire que pour
moi une journée
c'est
48h vraiment on est bouleversé à chaque
fois qu'on entend le papa de Lola parler
il a des mots tellement juste tellement
fort il est il est il est tellement vrai
on se met tellement à sa place et je
suis vrai vraiment je pense à lui tous
les jours depuis que j'ai vu son son
interview et la semaine dernière et
cette nouvelle cette semaine il explique
aussi qu'il redoute le procès forcément
il a peur que la responsabilité de la
tueuse pe peut pour être mise en cause à
cause de son état psychologique instable
ça c'est on en avait on l'avait évoqué
ici lors de l'affaire regardez il y a
une contreexertise qui a été demandée
par son avocat ou ce qui est normal qui
peut remettre en question sa
responsabilité pénale et donc la tenue
d'un procès est-ce que ça vous le
redoutez ah oui je le redoute c'est mais
son avocat effectivement il fait son
travail si le procès a lieu elle encour
la prison à perpétuité ouais ce procès
vous l'attendez ou il vous
estais un peu des deux mais oui je
l'attends parce que il y a un moment
faut passer à autre chose et puis
essayer en tout cas h ouais essayer on
va
dire très très dur ce témoignage alors
Michel Marie laffire l' là donc ce sera
le procès en 2024 c'est ça je pense pas
que ça vienne en 2024 on n'est pas du
tout dans les délais ça sera encore plus
long ah oui probablement plus long le
délai raisonnable aujourd'hui entre le
moment où les faits sont commis et le
moment où l'auteur enfin le suspect
passe comparé devant la Cour d'Assise
c'est minimum 3 ans d'abord il y a un an
et demi d'instruction minimum c'est
souvent 2 ans il faut dire que les juges
instruction en moyenne 170 ou0 dossiers
en
simultané à gérer et le juge il est tout
seul je vous dis il faut donner donner
des moyen à la justice parce que les
juges il peuvent pas tout faire non plus
pas traiter 180 dossiers par an il faut
peut-être ouvrir moins
d'information en c'est très compliqué
donc pour en venir au délai la moyenne
c'est 3 ans parce qu'après c'est pas une
fois que le juge a renvoyé le le dossier
à clôturer son dossier après il y a un
problème de
d'audiencement euh il y a des affaires
il y a à Paris je crois qu'il y a quatre
cours d'assise qui tournent à plein
régime et en
permanence et là encore les délais sont
sont longs un procès comme celui de de
de Dabia ce sera minimum une semaine
d'audience minimum ou G s'il y a un
procès ah oui parce que là c'est toute
la question hein elle a quand même
quitté la la prison de freine elle est
internée dans une unité spéciale pour
malad très difficile à ville juif et si
la première expertise a dit qu'il y
avait pas de trouble psychique ou
neuropsychique il y aura une
contreexertise et vu son état
psychologique aujourd'hui elle se tapait
la tête contre les mur alors est-ce
qu'elle en fait trop est-ce qu'elle a
joué un peu ça c'est possible mais en
tout cas Cyril rien ne garantit
aujourd'hui qu'elle sera jugée un jour
alors on vrait parler d'une autre
affaire parce qu'on va oui vou dire oui
je voulais dire que il faut pas il faut
pas crier avant d'avoir avant d'avoir
mal ou mais bon quand même là dans ces
caslà il vaut mieux non mais il y a une
première expertise qui dit qu'elle n'est
pas atteinte de de troubles mentaux
effectivement elle a été mise dans une
unité de pour malade difficile mais plus
pour la préserver pour éviter qu'elle se
suicide elle était placée à l'isolement
et elle supportait pas l'isolement et
l'intérêt de tout le monde c'est qu'elle
arrive saine et sauve devant la Cour
d'ASS excusez-moi mais je peux pas
entendre ça quand je vois ce que vit cet
homme elle ne supportait pas l'isolement
mais qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire
qu'elle supporte pas l'isolement
excusez-moi qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire
de la protéger on va payer pour la
protéger des années avec ce qu'on entend
là moi excuse moi je peux pas entendre
je vais vous répondre l'idée c'est
simplement qu'elle arrive au procès
vivante si elle se pend dans sa cellule
on aura tout perdu et et donc ça je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas
forcément faire offense à à à la famille
des victimes que de la placer dans une
unité
médicale pour les gens difficiles pour
pas qu'elle se su je sais ce que tu
penses moi oui moi moi je moi vous savez
tout ce que je pense mais mais le
problème c'est que pourquoi 3 ans en
fait
l' 180 mais y a pas 180 comme ça est-ce
qu'on peut pas passer un dossier en
pensant au monsieur qu'on vient de voir
à l'antenne qui est obligé d'attendre
qui divorce ce pauvre monsieur là est-ce
qu'il y a 180 cas de de de personnes de
petit de petites filles qu'on a mis dans
un coffre dans une malle qu'on a
transporté à boisom qu'on a ramené à
Paris peut-être qu' un moment donné on
pourrait se dire ça ça ça va
passer on a tout on a toutes les preuves
on sait qui c'est on sait qui a fait ça
elle avoué voilà un moment donné ce que
justice peut pas dire là on n pas là
pour parler de la justice et faire leur
dire comment on doit faire mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire ça en plus rapide
que 3 ans bien sûr est-ce qu'on peut
pasid ou question mais c'est tellement
logique vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit
il a dit que ses journées faisait 48 he
au lieu de 24 heur que il attend ça pour
essayer de tourner une page vous rendez
compte il y a la justice mais il y a de
l'humanité aussi enfin marche sur la
tête quoi je sais bien que c'est engorgé
mais on me pose une question et je
réponds
à pas lui vrai on a toutes les infos
alors on va on voudrait pas revenir sur
l'affaire Lina on va rappeler juste
l'affaire Lina parce que c'est vrai qu'
plein d'affaires en ce moment au cours
le petit Émile qu'on a toujours pas
retrouvé Lina toujours pas retrouvé Lina
non toujours pas non mais c'est
incroyable il se passe quoi dans
toujours pas bah on la retrouve pas on n
pas retrouvé non plus ilst ils savent
toujours pas ce qu'il y a dans le
téléphone de Tao son petit ami alors si
un peu donc le le téléphone de
Tao l'information qu'on a c'est qu'il ne
bornait pas euh dans le dans le village
où cette petite jeune fille a disparu au
moment où elle a disparu ce qui ne veut
pas dire que il était avec son téléphone
parce que le téléphone c'est toujours
c'est pas la preuve absolue c'est une
béquille de l'enquête mais c'est pas la
preuve absolue euh vous laissez votre
téléphone chez vous venez ici on va
penser que vous êtes chez vous alors que
vous êtes là bien sûr mais sinon il y a
pour l'instant pas pas de suspect
potentiel alors pas de suspect potentiel
et pour en pour en oui non il y a pas de
suspect potentiel
euh mais ça arrive hein c'est pas euh
c'est incroyable euh